GLASS.
DANA PERINO.
"THE FIVE" ."
IF YOU WERE IN NEW YORK TODAY,
YOU MAY BE WONDERING WHY EVERY
JOURNALIST IS WALKING AROUND
BREATHING INTO A PAPER SACK.
IT'S BECAUSE DONALD TRUMP IS
GIVING A MAJOR TELEVISED ADDRESS
ABOUT THE BORDER.
WHATEVER HE SAYS, YOU KNOW THAT
IT WILL BE FACT-CHECKED BY
LIBERAL JOURNALISTS WHO COME
UNDER OBAMA, WERE MYSTERIOUSLY
AWOL.
BUT NONE OF THIS MATTERS TO
NANCY OR CHUCK WHO HAVE MADE THE
POLITICAL PERSONAL.
IF YOU HAVE AGREED TO WHAT TRUMP
WANTS MANY TIMES BEFORE, LARRY
REJECTING IT NOW?
THE BORDER HAS ONLY GOTTEN WORSE
SINCE DEMOCRATS SAID THIS.
>> AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
FUNDAMENTALLY PRO-ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION AND ANTI-ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
>> I VOTED NUMEROUS TIMES AND I
WAS A SENATOR TO SPEND MONEY TO
BUILD A BARRIER.
>> WE SIMPLY CANNOT ALLOW PEOPLE
TO POUR INTO THE UNITED STATES
UNDETECTED, UNDOCUMENTED,
UNCHECKED.
>> Greg: BUT NOW THEIR STORY
HAS CHANGED.
WHY?
HAS THE SITUATION IMPROVED?
HARDLY.
BUT THEY RECALCULATED.
THEY CAN AGREE WITH TRUMP OR
DECIDE THAT THAT IS WORSE THAN
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND DRUG
SMUGGLING.
IN 2016, MORE THAN 20,000
UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN WERE
STOPPED AT THE MEXICAN BORDER, A
102% JUMP IN THE PREVIOUS YEAR.
WE DON'T KNOW HOW MANY GOT PAST
THE BORDER PATROL AND I.C.E.
THAT WON'T MATTER TO CHUCK AND
NANCY BECAUSE HUMAN TRAFFICKING
MAY BE BAD BUT NOT AS BAD AS
COOPERATING WITH SOMEONE THEY
HATE.
THIS INACTION ISN'T NEW.
IN '14, OBAMA WAS CRITICIZED
WHEN IN ONE MONTH MORE THAN
10,000 UNACCOMPANIED KIDS WERE
STOPPED AND RELEASED AT THE
BORDER, DOUBLING FROM THE
PREVIOUS YEAR.
THE DEMS WERE CRITICIZED FOR
IGNORING THE WARNINGS JUST AS
THEY SHOULD BE CRITICIZED NOW.
IT WASN'T AN EMERGENCY THEN AND
THE DEMS DID NOTHING.
TRUMP IS ACTUALLY TRYING TO DO
SOMETHING AND THEY ARE JUST
STANDING IN THE WAY.
WHY?
THEY HATE HIM.
THEY CAN'T LET HIM WIN EVEN IF
IT SAVES THE LIVES OF WOMEN AND
CHILDREN WHICH IS WHY THE ONLY
WALL YOU'RE GOING TO SEE WITH
CHUCK AND NANCY.
ALL RIGHT, I GUESS WE SHOULD GO
AROUND THE HORN HERE AS THEY
SAY.
I WILL START WITH YOU, DANA.
THAT'S A LOVELY COLOR.
WE ARE ALL WEARING A LITTLE BIT
OF A --
>> Dana: COLLABORATIVE?
>> Greg: I STOP IT.
WHAT SHOULD HE SAY TONIGHT?
>> Dana: THIS IS A BIG DEAL.
IF YOU THINK OF THE
COMMUNICATIONS TOOLBOX OF A
PRESIDENT, THIS IS THE HAMMER.
IT'S THE STRONGEST TOOL.
HE HASN'T USED IT HERETOFORE.
OBVIOUSLY IT'S HIS MOST
IMPORTANT ISSUE.
HE THINKS THIS IS THE ONE THING
HE WANTS TO ADDRESS THE NATION
FROM THE OVAL OFFICE ON.
THERE IS SIGNIFICANT IN THAT.
IT'S AN EIGHT MINUTE SPEECH SO
YOU'VE GOT TO PACK A BIG PUNCH
INTO 8 MINUTES.
HIS CHANCE TO TALK TO ALL
AMERICANS.
IT'S NOT A CAMPAIGN RALLY.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE CAN SAY
THAT WILL MOVE THE NEEDLE.
I LOOKED AT POLLING FROM 2016,
DECEMBER 2016 TO DECEMBER 2018
WHERE HE TALKED ABOUT THE WALL
AND IMMIGRATION NONSTOP FOR TWO
YEARS.
STILL OPPOSITION TO THE WALL IS
54%.
IT HASN'T CHANGED AT ALL.
CAN HE DO SOMETHING TONIGHT AND
THESE 8 MINUTES TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE?
IT'S POSSIBLE.
>> Greg: INTERESTING.
JESSE, WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THE MATTER?
>> Jesse: MAYBE OPPOSITION TO
THE WALL IS HOW YOU PHRASE THE
QUESTION IN THE POLLING.
WE TALK ABOUT BORDER SECURITY
AND SENTENCING AND THINGS LIKE
THAT, YOU GET A DIFFERENT
ANSWER.
I THINK THAT MEDIA ISN'T SCARED
THAT HE'S GOING TO TELL LIES.
I THINK THE MEDIA SCARED HE'S
GOING TO TELL THE TRUTH AND THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
LISTEN AND HE'S GOING TO BE
PERSUASIVE.
AS YOU SAID, THESE ARE VERY
POWERFUL SPEECHES.
IT'S HIS FIRST ONE FROM THE
OVAL OFFICE.
PEOPLE ARE SAYING THERE'S NOT A
CRISIS.
IT'S FUNNY BECAUSE THIS IS FROM
"THE WASHINGTON POST," DANA.
JUST A FEW DAYS AGO.
"AFTER YEARS OF TRUMP'S DIRE
WARNINGS, A "CRISIS" HAS HIT THE
BORDER BUT GENERATES LITTLE
URGENCY."
THIS IS BY THEIR CHIEF NATIONAL
SECURITY CORRESPONDENT AND CHIEF
BORDER SECURITY CORRESPONDENT.
THEY SAY AT RECORD NUMBERS OF
MIGRANT FAMILY STREAMING INTO
THE UNITED STATES, OVERWHELMING
BORDER AGENTS AND LEAVING
HOLDING CELLS DANGEROUSLY
OVERCROWDED.
>> Greg: ON WHAT IS THE DATE?
>> Jesse: JANUARY 5.
>> Greg: THIS IS FROM DECEMBER 6
>> Greg: THIS IS FROM DECEMBER ,
>> Greg: THIS IS FROM DECEMBER 2
>> Greg: THIS IS FROM DECEMBER 1
>> Greg: THIS IS FROM DECEMBER .
ON THE COURT CROSSING THE BORDER
AND GROWING NUMBERS AGAINST
PARKING CONCERNS THAT THE NEW
INFLUX OF CHILDREN WOULD
EVENTUALLY REACH LEVELS TO
DECLARE HUMANITARIAN CRISIS.
>> Jesse: IT USED TO BE
MEXICAN ADULT MALES.
NOW IT'S ADULTS WITH CHILDREN
COMING FROM CENTRAL AMERICA AND
LEGAL YOU CAN'T HOLD THEM
TOGETHER.
POLITICALLY YOU CAN'T SEPARATE
THEM, AND YOU CAN'T SEND THEM
BACK QUICKLY.
THERE'S ABOUT 60,000 COMING
ACROSS EACH MONTH.
WE HAVE DECLARED CRISES, THE
LEFT AND THE MEDIA.
WE HAD A GLOBAL WARMING CRISIS.
WE HEADED IN INCOME INEQUALITY
CRISIS.
HOW MANY PEOPLE DID THAT KILL,
JUAN?
OPIOID CRISIS, STUDENT LOAN
CRISIS.
YOU CAN MAKE EMERGENCY --
>> Dana: DON'T FORGET THE
FINANCIAL CRISIS.
>> Jesse: SCHOOL SHOOTING
CRISIS.
EVERYONE WOULD AGREE THAT WAS A
CRISIS LAST YEAR.
29 PEOPLE WERE KILLED IN SCHOOL
SHOOTINGS.
IN ONE YEAR ALONE, JUST IN
TEXAS, THERE WERE 32 ILLEGAL
ALIENS CONVICTED OF HOMICIDE.
THAT'S JUST IN ONE STATE.
MORE DEADLY IN THIS SITUATION
THEN IT IS IN ALMOST ANY OTHER
SITUATION.
>> Greg: JUAN, JESSE IS
POINTING OUT HE IS GOING AGAINST
THE COMMON ASSUMPTIONS ON OTHER
NETWORKS THAT THAT THERE IS NO
CRISIS.
DO YOU AGREE WITH JESSE?
I THINK YOU SHOULD.
>> Jesse: AND
"THE WASHINGTON POST."
>> Juan: I DON'T UNDERSTAND
HOW PEOPLE ARE SMART AND CAPABLE
AND THOUGHTFUL WOULD NOT SEE
THROUGH THIS CHARADE.
I TELL YOU WHAT.
>> Greg: WAS OBAMA STUPID?
>> Juan: OBAMA DIDN'T DECLARE
A NATIONAL CRISIS.
TONIGHT WHEN THE PRESIDENT
SPEAKS, ONE OF THE OPTIONS IN
HIS TOOLBOX, AS DANA SAID, THAT
HE WOULD DECLARE THIS AS A
NATIONAL CRISIS.
IT WOULD GIVE HIM SOME POWERS
AND A CONVERGED TAKE MONEY OUT
OF THE DEFENSE BUDGET AND THE
LIKE.
IS THIS 9/11?
IS IT PEARL HARBOR?
IS IT THE '09 RECESSION,
DEPRESSION?
NO, IT'S NOTHING.
THE INVASION FROM THE CARAVAN
BEFORE THE MIDTERMS, .
>> Greg: TWO CHILDREN DIED.
>> Juan: OH, PLEASE.
THE NUMBERS ARE PRETTY CLEAR.
APPREHENSIONS THE BORDER ARE
GOING DOWN, DOWN, DOWN.
IN FACT, THE PRESIDENT AND SARAH
HUCKABEE SANDERS WERE SAYING
OVER THE WEEKEND 4,000 PEOPLE,
THESE TERRORISTS.
NO, NOT TRUE.
>> Greg: SHOULD NOTHING GET
DONE?
JUST LIKE WHAT HAPPENED IN 2015?
IT'S EXACTLY WHAT'S BETWEEN NINE
SAID.
-- IT'S EXACTLY WHAT DEMS SAID.
>> Juan: APPREHENDING AT THE
CANADIAN BORDER BACK IN MAY
'90s.
TO ME THE BIG NEWS IS THE
PRESIDENT IS FINALLY STARTING TO
TALK ABOUT HUMANITARIAN CRISIS.
I THINK THAT'S WHERE HE CAN GET
OUT OF HIS BOX.
HE'S IN A BOX RIGHT NOW, A
POLITICAL BOX OF HIS OWN MAKING.
THE WAY HE'S TRYING TO GET OUT
OF IT WAS CAN I USE THIS TOOL,
THAT TOOL?
MAYBE IF HE STARTS TALKING ABOUT
THE HUMANITARIAN SUFFERING OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE COMING TO THIS
COUNTRY AND HOW WE PROPERLY DEAL
WITH IT AND COMPREHENSIVE
IMMIGRATION REFORM.
>> Greg: I THINK HE HAS TRIED
TO DO THAT, EMILY.
BUT WHEN YOU'RE CONSTANTLY
CALLED A BIGOT FOR TRYING TO
CREATE A STRONGER BORDER, IT'S A
CHALLENGE WHEN YOU HAVE THE
ENTIRE MEDIA AGAINST YOU.
>> Emily: EGG CAPABLE,
THOUGHTFUL PERSON THINKS IT IS A
CRISIS.
FOR EVERYONE ON THE LEFT WHO IS
SAYING THERE'S SOME TYPE OF
GEOGRAPHICAL CONTAINMENT THAT
HAPPENS OF THE BORDER, THAT'S
NOT TRUE.
FOR ALL THE POINTS THE DEMS SAY
THEY CARE ABOUT OR THAT THEY DO
CARE ABOUT, THEY ARE DIRECTLY
ATTRIBUTABLE TO THE SOUTHERN
BORDER, THE OPIOID MPEG      EPI
BORDER, THE OPIOID MPEG      EPE
BORDER, THE OPIOID MPEG      EP.
>> Juan: MOST DRUGS DON'T COME
OVER THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
>> Greg: >> Greg: >
>> Greg: >> Greg: E
>> Greg: >> Greg: i
>> Greg: >> Greg: H
>> Greg: >> Greg: R
>> Greg: >> Greg: '
>> Greg: >> Greg: S
>> Greg: >> Greg: T
>> Greg: >> Greg: E
>> Greg: >> Greg: -
>> Greg: >> Greg: I
WANT OUT POINT OUT HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IS THE THIRD-LARGEST
CRIMINAL INTERNATIONAL INDUSTRY
AND THE PLANETS BEHIND DRUGS AND
ARMS.
A $32 BILLION INDUSTRY.
GUESS WHO PLEDGED OUR TAX
DOLLARS TO COMBAT IT?
THE DOJ.
HOW IS THAT NOT EFFECTING
EVERYTHING A PERSON?
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE REFORM THAT
HOPEFULLY EVERYONE IS SUPPORTING
I'M TALKING ABOUT A DISPARATE
IMPACT MINORITIES AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES.
THERE'S SO MANY INTERWOVEN
THINGS THAT ARE ATTRIBUTABLE TO